today uh when when i meet
great entrepreneurs
uh i think that they have great jedi
forces they know where they want to be
they know where are the dots
and and the cfo is there to create a
plan out of it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am joined by ron
reinfeld chief financial officer at
morphysec prior to joining morphysec ron
served as chief financial officer at
insights acquired by rapid7 where he
oversaw global finance legal hr and
planning operations ron brings over 15
years of financial leadership experience
at sas companies he was vp of finance
and operations at zoos acquired by payu
and has held various financial and
operational roles at cloudshare clarizen
and ernest and young where he
specialized in technology ipos and m a's
in addition ron has held multiple
advisory roles at early stage tech
startups
ron reinfeldt welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so so much for being
with me today how are you
i'm good thank you so much for having me
it's exciting i didn't see a lot of cfos
in the previous sessions which i enjoyed
and i think we can give a new fresh air
for the cfos around us
well i'm excited to you know go deep
into what it means to be a chief
financial officer of an organization as
an as an engineer and product you know
myself i have to say i'm really scared
of cfos i'm scared of the term and and
i'm really excited to you know finish
these 20 minutes with a new light and
new hope for myself and then for some of
my friends to understand what this
position is all about
and i definitely couldn't pick somebody
better to to to sort of dumb it down you
know the profession for me than somebody
who was born on april 15th
so thank you very very much for joining
me thank you for having me again looking
forward
it's usually in every sense i want to
hear the fun story
whenever there's a sales kickoff when
i'm joining a new company and there's
also and it's something interesting
about you every time i i pop up the
april 15th the tax day that's when they
know that i'm not just mad about
something that i can bring something
back to the table
beautiful beautiful all right so so one
you know a lot to uncover here long to
unpack you've been with finance for a
long time and you've been holding
you know executive positions starting
from you know from vp finance and
incredible companies like like cloud
share member for the advisory board and
my role vp finance at zoos and
most recently cfo of insights and cfo of
morphe sec currently
lots of interesting positions you've
seen a lot you've experienced a lot what
is the chief financial officer position
in a company
it's a great question and i think for
many entrepreneurs it's also a question
and sometimes it's hard to to find the
right one
because it's not exactly known to
everyone what exactly we're doing in
that dark room
uh that all of the excels and data is
coming out of
so i think that at the end of the day
for the management and and for the board
it's it's that
person or that place that provides you
what the number are telling
it's the place that if you're a ceo it's
the places you can come open say the
truth
no one will be frustrated everything's
okay you can fix everything you can calm
down everything work on a different plan
listen have open discussion because
i usually joke with my friends that
sometimes entrepreneurs
i i call it the the muhammad ali effect
they are getting so many punches from so
many places it can come from the from
the investors from the team from their
peers and there's one place that needs
to happen guys this is where you want to
go how they want to do it
and and and i think that today uh when
when i meet
great entrepreneurs
uh i think that they have great jedi
forces they know where they want to be
they know where are the dots
and and the cfo is there to create a
plan out of it and it's it's a reality
check and a real plan that you can
monitor and see what is going on uh
on every day and and clearly we are here
to see and and
make sure that we invest in our dream
uh we have a clear runway and we make
sure that all of the efforts and
resources are going to the right place
right now
you know i'm looking at a startup and
i'm looking at a leadership team and i'm
you know i'm imagining a group of people
that are totally visionaries they're you
know breaking walls you know move fast
and break things and and constantly
being very very optimistic
where on the re on the scale between you
know very being very realistic and very
you know in the present versus being
very you know bold visionary and you
know futuristic where does the cfo lie
because oftentimes i'm imagining cfo's
joining early companies how how do you
balance those two things
so
so i think at the end of the day
when you work with a strong team and
you're there to orchestrate and make
sure that
the story is cohesive and it aligns with
what the number are saying
then this is the point that is able to
make the the leg work
not for the ceo directly with the with
the management what but for the cfo and
the management team to align together
and come prepared to the ceo
and and make their uh
argument clear because when you show it
and you support with data
then the decisions are easier and we are
all here to make fast decisions as as
you said we are always pushing for
decisions even if we go wrong that's
okay we'll fix it fast and we do
something different but we need to open
our ears and our eyes and just face
reality and that will make us move very
very fast
on many on many cases
it's
the cfo is getting tasks that no one
else wants to do
that's a part of what you do
and they can go around administration
they can go around processes they can go
for creating the operating plan
to make sure that we are heading to the
to the right direction i wanted to
transition to
hearing a little bit about your personal
experiences as a cfo and so you've seen
you know multiple companies multiple
positions you've grew as an executive in
the cfo positions what was the
experience like on a personal level for
you coming into companies and seeing
through some some really incredible
financial transactions and and strategic
decisions being made in the life cycle
of the company i'm going to say cliche
but but the most important thing
is
us the people and getting to a good
relationship with the management team
that's the core thing that is extremely
important
um
it's getting making sure that they know
that even though you sometimes present
numbers that are not totally aligned
with the story that we want to tell
and making sure that they know that we
can work on a plan together to align it
and make us as the team stronger i think
that's that's the the core of it if the
ceo feels comfortable coming frustrated
into my office and call me at whatever
hour he feels
just because you know
as i said before there is one person in
this company who is there to help him
hundred percent on any on any front by
the way
uh and and i think being listen
we're doing something great
we need to move fast let's take a deep
breath look at things again and then
make sure we do it right
i've been to multiple companies
and part of them i was there for the
first po that they ever got
and we got to to companies that were
crossing the tens of millions which is
it's fascinating and i think that
it was interesting to me to go through
that because at the beginning uh
more experienced cfos told me there's a
huge difference between the c force
going to be between zero to five million
five to twenty something and more than
that and
then i started to understand it because
there is so much to do on the back end
of a company if it's indexing the data
in the right way if it's creating the
right dialogue if it's making sure that
i understand every process that is going
through how does customer success
influence what we do and how can i
influence the things that we have the
most uh that will be most beneficial for
us to fix if we are targeting uh churn
or nlr or any other synonym and you know
it's funny because always the the tech
the tech guys have synonyms that i don't
understand and i'm not shy guys i just
don't understand what you just said
please explain so when it comes to nr
and things like that it's okay and it's
a good discussion to have
and and if we know that it's going to be
a challenging year why are we where
should we focus
and and it's all
going back
to creating that team that can talk
openly
again
in my old days i used to play water polo
for many years i was in the israeli
cadet team
and there are two things that i think i
took from that experience
the first one is work hard put your head
in the water and just keep on swimming
the second thing is not to avoid the
conflict
or discuss it
and and and solve it before it gets to
it to a place that it's hard to recover
and i think that that is maybe my
biggest lesson in that because sometimes
when you you know you can come as the
cmo or cro
and you know this is your play and this
is what you want to achieve this is what
you want to present and then part of
what you're saying i can't justify with
the numbers
and it's up to me to make sure that you
know i'm your partner i'm not here to
make you feel bad
i'm not here to make you
embarrassed and i always take the calls
beforehand i never surprise an executive
in in in a management meeting sure not
in a board meeting but they know exactly
where are the differences so we will
come together to that meeting and we
will create the assurance that our ceo
and our investors
want us to create
and i think for me it's a huge it's a
huge lesson it's not always easy
and and sometimes you know pointing fpo
which is a bad peel which is going to
influence us in a bad direction is not
easy to say
and and and it's it's a part you know
you can see by the gray hair i made many
mistakes uh and i'm sure i'll make more
but i'm trying to reduce them as much as
possible
now how attached do you think you as a
cfo need to be to the mission of the
company to the vision of the company on
a product level on a technology level
in order to be a successful cfo for that
company 100
if i can't explain what i'm doing as a
company if i can't understand where is
my focus point then it's very hard for
me to to understand what is going on
uh i think that and and i'm pushing my
teams all the time to be close to the
field to be close to the product no
making sure that we are able to show the
r d and the product
exactly how do they make a difference if
they want to change something if they
want to add more capabilities even
reporting i need to understand the big
picture and make sure i provide this
data all the time so if it works well
then we won't if it's not working well
so let's just fix it and if i don't get
it and if it's hard for me to get it i
think i'm not
optimizing my abilities in in enabling
and and going back to what you asked
before i said i think that the cfo is a
big enabler of things in the company
and and i can't see a cfo being
successful without understanding the
mission vision
even values at the end of the day
it's all aligned to one place and there
is
we get the the the very interesting
thing that we see
everything from start to end
both on data and also on the tactical
things um
you know when when someone is asking me
how many options that i have is vested
i think it's i i learned that it's a
sign
and i i i hear and see what is happening
and it's all connected
uh and and
again being there and being a part of
all of it makes a huge difference and i
think i was more successful in companies
that i was very
aligned and and i knew exactly where
we're heading and that allows me to
create the right plan to get there
uh in our future beautiful so so what
i'm getting what i'm hearing from this
is you know if we're looking at a
successful cfo position you know it's
not just somebody who's crunching the
numbers and doing the excels but
somebody who's a part of the strategic
thinking process a part of the the
culture of the company is a part of the
leadership team
even to the point where you're gauging
you know what's happening with your own
human resources and what's happening
with your organization and and what the
different incentives are now really
let's talk details you know what does a
cfo do in the day-to-day i get you know
i know that an engineer mainly writes
code a product manager mainly you know
writes prds and takes meetings and the
designer mainly works on figma or
photoshop but what does a cfo actually
do
okay so so there are multiple layers for
that and then i'll try to go first at
least to the major ones
so
at the end of the day
we need to run the company's a runway we
need to make sure that we are getting to
the next financing round in the best
shape that we can
we need to make sure
that
the people understand that the budget
is a derivative of the operating plan
we meet we need to help creating that
plan in a way that we all have checks
and balances
throughout the way
cfo is not the one who's going through
expensify
and and just making sure that the
numbers are correct yes
we are a place of accuracy
we we demand that from ourselves
uh we are in a very interesting triangle
between founder investors and cfo and
and and we need to be at the end of the
day
the adult
on deck
because people will be looking at us
because we are not as as dreamers
as the founder are
we are not technical that's for sure
but we are able to
share the exact location of the where
the company is at and having the right
triggers in place to know when should we
pl a step on the pedal and when wouldn't
you just wait for a minute and see what
what is happening there are many
tactical things that we are doing tax
reports financial statements uh
commissions uh again there are many
things that that we're taking care and i
think
there is a difference between one cfo to
the other personally i i like operations
uh i'm running the devops organization i
think it
helps me
get to a better uh planning capability
and a better monitoring
tool for me um to have of course we're
always investigating
future financing options if it's debt
when is the right time to take debt
investments uh
peace
we have an open list of who is a
relevant uh
acquirer or a relevant pe that might be
interesting and trying to to to offload
many from the ceo
the things that he shouldn't be
concentrated in
and making sure that when he is needed
he is needed
so i'm i'm not sure i got into all of
the details honestly
well i think that what you're shedding
light for me is really about this this
idea of of holistic partnership that you
know you're not just some outsourced
figure that is helping crunch numbers
and you know be a blocker in many
essence to the to the leadership team
but you really are a partner in
everything that's happening with your
organization and your your job is to
enable the company to get to its best
financing round to get to the best
matrix to set the best kpis to
communicate the in the best way with the
board with the employees and with
everybody
how how did you find
were you successful in
informing this intimate relationship
with the leadership tim to so that
everybody feels like like you as a cfo
are part of this big ship you're not
just this you know realist guy who's who
is here to block but but you're here as
a part of the journey and everything
that you're doing is for the sake of the
company and not you know just for the
sake of financials
so so i think the journey starts and it
takes around three to five months until
you you really you're able to get to
that position and and
our my peers understand that whatever
needs to be done
we will make it happen it can be playing
with itself
it can be
you're the cro i'll make all of the
working documents for you i will call
you for the right time take a look at it
do the sanity check and it's not only
saying okay so uh state of the cloud
2021 said that the five c's should be
that
that won't help us enable anything it's
it's critical and the key bank
benchmarks are critical but there is
such a huge gap between
what we can bring to the table and what
the actual people know the zero which is
in the field and the cmo and the cto
they have so much things to take care of
and if we can take we can offload part
of that thing that because we are part
of our cpa so by definition
we think in a structured way
and and and
part of the people in the team are not
as structured and it's okay because
we're working together so we can take
care of that while you make sure we get
to that to the end result that we want
to get
so i think it takes a lot of back and
forth i think you know
numbers don't lie and cfo don't lie
don't lie
and if they do then you have a problem
uh and the minute that you understand
that the person in front of you will be
there for you on a personal level as
well by the way i think i think it's a
real partnership because
one thing that i love about uh
emerging fast growing tech companies
is that
i don't like the comparison to family
because you don't choose a family but
you do choose who you want to work with
and you want to make sure that i have
your back and i think that that that the
strong cfo will always have your back
and if there is an issue let's make sure
the next time it's it's done correctly
and and and i'm always starting with
everything that i meet and i'm sharing
my personal story where where i failed
what i want to achieve
how do i how how do i conduct my
discussions
and i need to make sure that there is
the right alignment between us because
otherwise i won't be able to to enable
the things that i want to enable
so so that's that's from that for me are
our key uh factors
um what do you enjoy most
about your daily work we're if you're
looking at you know the last 20 years
where where where is the biggest joy
that you're getting
well it's it's it's an it's it's amazing
so
again the biggest joy for me is being
able
to
identify that specific point that we are
getting off track or that we are
accelerating more than we wanted and
making sure that you are there when it
happens to block it or push it i think
it's one of the most exciting thing
for me the entire uh
tech experience is is amazing
i love the roller coaster in it you know
come to the office in the morning it's a
crazy day everything went so well then
you had a call with one of the investors
that wasn't happy and then you're just
going down that second and up later
because you see that the quarters are
being attained so that entire circle
when you drive back home wow it was a
nice day
and i'm trying to enjoy what i do
and and i think that and i think there
are many things that that we can enjoy
and i think that there are amazing
things that are happening here in our
industry
uh
one of the things that
it's it's quite an old post that was in
quora i'm sure familiar with that about
the bananas and working with israelis i
i'm not tell me about it so trying to
understand
oh oh
i was sending it away after the the
session
but
it's someone that is trying to share
with his friends how is it to work with
israelis and it starts with
a case study that
in the u.s they they wanted to have
banana straightened because the way that
this cereal is being eaten that it would
be easy to to to slice the the bananas
and there are two different teams one in
the us and one is in israel
so the u.s team
after 24 months they have
a full-blown product
uh the the next day they already posted
a job on linkedin they're doing all of
their research they are creating a
hundred percent machine that will be
ready in 36 months and it will i think
they say that they they will need
electricity power of a refrigerator
on the other hand
the guys from israel
in the second sentence they say that's a
stupid idea why are they interested in a
banana
and and on their way home they call a
friend that lives in the kibbutz and
asks them can we straighten a banana
and in i think it's the story says five
or six
which they create a machine
built out of uzi uh
um parts that is able to straighten 67
of the bananas the rest are
either squashed disappear or god knows
what happens it cost about five minutes
if i sorry five weeks to get the entire
thing ready end to end the cost per
machine is five dollars
uh and and
and when the ceo says
but you know 37 are are not straight and
since it was part of the prd and it's
and and and we're okay and we still
think it's a stupid idea
so
i think when when when you try to gather
all of that and
i think that again it's a part of being
an executive not not only a
cfo
but understanding that not everyone
across the table are talking in the same
jargon questioning thing is important to
a limit
pushing thing is good to a limit
doing research is the right thing to do
it shouldn't take six months but it
should happen
and and i think that in that dialer
we play an interesting role in that so
so that inspires me because i see the
good things and things we still need to
improve
and and and it's i'm sensitive either
way after the uh
i would love that and go on i i just
love
how i'm leaving this conversation with
with a really different perspective on
you know the type of cfo that i want to
get for my feature company and i'm
looking at
you know i'm just looking at a different
light and and i think that i i needed to
give more credit to
the strategic position and not just the
one that is going to be managing the
financial rounds and perhaps a an
optimistic acquisition at some point but
but really somebody who's a partner
along the way helping the leadership
team make the right decisions you know
put a mirror to what's happening in the
world but put the mirror not in in a
foreign light but in a teamwork and in
in an internal light to that that we can
just overcome together as a team and i
think that i i i'm just so thankful that
you join me for these 20 minutes and i
really appreciate your time and your
energy and your your record speaks for
itself with the incredible companies
that you've been a part of up until now
and i can't wait to see what what else
you're going to be doing so thank you
very very much and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you so much for having me and i
hope you you guys all of you will
understand that the cfos have so much to
give
sometimes it's difficult but the the
intent is good and work with them work
with them
let them let them talk let them share
put a limit to that because if they're
out of bounds
it shouldn't it shouldn't continue
and
again it's a pleasure to listen to your
sessions and thank you so much for
having me and i feel more physique is
going to be the next big thing
thank you very very much
[Music]